if a man is convinced that he really is
a woman like in some of those viral
videos we've all seen of the big Burly
man screaming in the bodega my name is
ma'am my name is ma'am and and he's
acting out in a way that is really
disorderly and disrupting the public and
harmful to himself for instance if he
wants to chop off his own healthy body
parts and and cause all sorts of
Destruction to himself then I think not
only is it the right of society to take
some action here to restore order but I
I think it's only compassionate for that
person I think it's a very selfish and
shallow kind of liberalism that says
that when when people have mental
problems we ought to just let them out
on the street often to die of exposure
or to go do drugs in some back alley in
San Francisco no we owe them help Brad
asks who am I to tell people what to do
why would I use the force of government
we live in America America is at least
supposed to be a self-government you're
a citizen with faculties of reason and a
moral conscience you can perceive truth
and it is not only your right but your
responsibility to do so to help your
kind of fellow country